[Music]
on today's show we talked to a father
who is not on the same page with his
wife when it comes to parenting i talked
to a cross-country coach who is
struggling with helicopter parents and
we also talk to an awesome guy who
wonders if he drinks too much and how he
might quit stay tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's up everybody this is john
with the dr john dolone's show and why
are we yelling i have no idea i have no
idea that was a little bit much
i am back we're filming this the day
after labor day so you may hear it
sometime in i don't know march or
something i don't even know where we are
or maybe it'll be next week and james is
back oh to see his smiling face and his
cute hair cut he looks so good
and kelly just looks brilliant as ever
oh man so my wife's out of town
and this morning we did school with me
and the two little ones
to all you single parents out there
may the force be with you i don't even
know what cosmic thing to send to you
may god bless you and keep you what's
the right thing to say here i don't even
know i don't know how you do it is what
i'm saying
i don't know i i
making lunches is a thing oh and by the
way i'm wearing a green shirt today
because i thought i put on my disco
clothes here at
at the office they said i just wear dark
sad tones like i'm trying to bring goth
back can you bring goth back i think
goth is over goth never went away
it just long chemical romance as long as
robert smith wears lipstick then goth is
still here i yes and typo negative i
don't think they're yeah i think they've
all moved on to
darker pastures but
i think we're all still with them and
then my chemical romance was keeping it
going and then they passed it on blink
182 even they're trying to get sad but
um i'm wearing this green shirt because
uh
since we're going to the club after this
oh man
everybody doing good
yeah doing great
glad to be back what happened when i was
gone we did not a say anything negative
about you at all ever
um b
shows went perfect and smooth
with or without you
kelly was uh producing produced the crap
out of him that's what i have to say
what do you think no
i agree how would you
how would you rank your um
uh performance your production
performance well especially since i was
doing my job and the production job i'd
give it a solid
here we go
tell him what you said to me when you
first walked in this morning though i
said he wasn't allowed to go anywhere
again because doing two jobs is hard
not that his job's hard he's doing his
job
a record
that's a beating that is a beating you
don't even have to do it answer the
phones and look over at the guy in the
seat and be like hey hit record you know
basically there's a whole lot of stuff
that goes on here outside of this
studio
that happens
so
well i'm glad everything nikki b you
doing good
yeah man doing great excellent all right
that's that's enough
around the horn here
i'm just gonna i feel like i'm i
feel like i'm wearing a neon sign
and it's like this sad muted green color
it just feels awkward but it's cool
though it's really not that it's not
that bright it looks like you know what
it is it's the collar buttons who wears
collar buttons you know who serial
killers that's who wear collar buttons
i'm just not a collar button guy and i'm
looking at a guy i like collar buttons
to me no collar buttons is more of a
disco shirt because they kind of flare
out and look like john travolta
as i was saying no uh no collar buttons
i looked at you and yours are yours are
buttoned down baby oh this got weird all
right let's go to al and houston what's
up al how's it going man
you're doing well dr d it's a blessing
to speak with you how are you you too my
man hey i'm gonna be in houston on
wednesday night doing an event with the
minimalists it's my favorite city except
for the one i live in i guess you're
supposed to say that i still love
houston hope you guys are doing good man
the honor's all mine how can i help man
yes so a little bit of context so
i'm looking for some wisdom from you
my wife and i have have
contrasting
parenting styles when it comes to
disciplining our little boys
we have two boys three and five
my wife is is very passive
she tries to
to reason with with the boys she's not
much on
strong discipline
and can contrast myself
i was raised that you know you do what
you're told and you do it the first time
and i was also raised that spanking was
appropriate
um
and so i i tried to instill that in my
boys but i try to do it sparingly
um but
uh because of the fact that we have
contrasting parroting styles
um it causes lots of arguments and fight
in the home
um and it's it's very toxic at times
because the boys see it and yeah i'm
just looking for some wisdom on
how to handle this
um with my wife
and just what i can do differently maybe
as a dad
so that i'm
you know raising these boys in a good
environment that's awesome man well
um dude i appreciate your heart it's
awesome there's not a lot of dads who
will step back and say hey hey what am i
bringing to this and be
i think i'm doing it right but i want my
boys to have better than what they're
getting right now so dude i
shout out to you and all the dads trying
to trying to get better at this so i
think you know this but i'm just going
to say it out loud right now your boys
this has nothing to do with discipline
right this second this has everything to
do with a power struggle between you and
your wife you and the one up position
her and the one down and your boys are
the proxy right so we'll get to the the
um the developmental stuff and the
discipline stuff
but we all have to agree you and your
wife that they are not going to be the
proxy war for your marriage right now
is that fair right
right
so
backing out um
we didn't have to go thirty thousand
feet we can go five thousand feet on
this one
what else is going on in your marriage
this isn't the only thing
no it's not it's not the only thing um
like i can i can tell you we've worked
on many things as a couple and we've
gotten through a lot um we've recently
um went through marriage counseling um
and
i i can just tell you it was it was it
was put on pause because
my wife felt like um all the problems
and blame were being put on her i mean
she even she even mentioned that she
felt like the counselor was putting
everything on her okay and so
um
you know i put up i told i asked my wife
i said you know how do you want to
you know continue this forward i mean i
don't want to pressure you into
something that
you know you're struggling with you're
feeling uncomfortable with
but you know at the same time
you know i still think there's things we
need to work on
and i can tell you uh
dr d the biggest thing is just with her
and i it's just communication that's our
biggest breakdown it's our biggest
struggle okay no we don't have we don't
have arguments
really about anything else other than
like i mentioned before it's it's we
have different parenting styles and then
our communication at times is just
really really poor
okay
and by poor do you lash out you
shouldn't you seem like a guy that um
is pretty regimented that does things
the right way because there's the right
way to do them
and then you'll sit on it and you'll try
to be qui your way of not overreacting
is being quiet being quiet and then it
uh is it kind of becomes a pressure
cooker is that you or do i miss it
that's fair that's very fair okay and i
do i mean i've definitely struggled
in the past with
controlling my anger and um i've gotten
a lot better with it i'm very confident
that but it's something i'm gonna always
have to work on where does um i think
you can i think you can get there
quicker than than not and to where it's
not something you always have to work on
i actually think you can heal from that
in pretty dramatic ways if you choose to
where did you learn that where'd you
learn anger
in well growing up um
i don't know i think it
has to do with a few things i used to
get picked on and bullied as a little
kid yeah but i think some of that has to
do with it um
other part of it
my
my mom she wasn't much of the
disciplinarian in the home um
she was more of the yelling type
so i think i picked some of that up as
well
was your old man around
yes i have a amazing amazing dad okay
he's he's my best friend did he um
how did he discipline you
um he was he was very quiet and reserved
um but but um
i mean he was very stern i mean he he
set expectations and uh he expected you
to follow his expectations and if you
didn't
um you know you you were going to get
you're going to get a spanking from it
okay and and i mean at the time as a kid
you know i
i didn't really like it but
as a man growing up looking back i
i know it helped me a bunch because i
just remember looking back on getting a
spanking and then after
reflecting on why he did what he did
it seemed to help me a lot okay
so
um i'm gonna i'm gonna take the spanking
thing i'm gonna move that aside because
that's a whole other show and it's a
complex thing
but i do want to
connect some dots for you okay
and i'm not doing this in a
controversial way i grew up with with a
very strong stern dad as well who i also
think i've benefited from dramatically
okay
um
there's a multiple things going on in
your home
and
right wrong or indifferent you and your
wife have to heal your marriage to he to
then be able to get on the same page
about this parenting thing so when i say
the one up position
is when guys who struggle with
um
as soon as i say this word you're gonna
be like no bro so don't tune me out when
i say this okay but guys who struggle
with
depression who struggle with strength
who struggle with
where do i fit in a power hierarchy
guys who were bullied growing up guys
who were
hit for stepping out of line by someone
who they consider their best friend
okay and we'll circle back to that
they often will puff their chest up and
lead try to lead from a one-up position
meaning
there is a right way i have bigger
muscles than you henceforth this is how
we're gonna live okay
and that sounds like you
on the other side folks who grew up
either
you be quiet shut your mouth it didn't
hurt
um who have any sort of trauma often um
women are put in this position because
that's just the way their world is they
lead in a one-down position which is
well i guess i'll just stay at home then
and um
i uh
yeah um
trying to explain and rationalize to a
three-year-old right um we don't need
everybody just hey hey let's just does
that make sense am i describing your
wife yes
okay
so they try to
run the household and the way i picture
it is they're underneath the water
pulling a boat
but they're underneath it and they can
slowly drag the whole house down does
that make sense
yes and so you got two people competing
for power one trying to drag the boat
down one trying to pull it back up and
these three this three-year-old and this
five-year-old are in the middle
okay
spanking is a complex thing
yelling is never i i think yelling is a
high form of abuse in a house it's never
cool it's never cool right
rationalizing and trying to quote
unquote explain things to a
three-year-old is almost a disservice
um equal to because their brains don't
work does that make sense they have to
see it it has to be modeled for them
right right and so
backing all the way out then you get to
spanking again that's a whole other
complex it's a third rail
but
imagine trying to wrap your head around
a kid
who is um
i love you
and i'm going to hit you
for falling out of line
that's a gap for us for a five-year-old
for a three-year-old does that make
sense right now i've spanked my kids and
that's a that's a whole other
conversation that will have a different
time but i want you to back all the way
out when you tell a five-year-old you
will do this or i will physically strike
you and i love you there is always a gap
there okay
sure
and so what i want you to back all the
way out and do this
a kids watch
they watch their periods and that's how
they learn how to interact with each
other with their teachers with their
friends
um
that's how they learn how to um
do things and not do things
right so if there is tension in that
home they are absorbing that number two
kids are desperate to be seen
and so if you are folks who are on the
phone if you guys are always watching tv
if you and your wife are yelling at each
other your kids will do whatever they
can to be seen
and so finding some ways that you can
let them know that you see them and that
you love them upstream tends to shift
and and change some of that behavior
number three giving them
um being very open about you have a role
in this family and here's how this works
and with a three-year-old and a
five-year-old always looping back to
hey we all agreed this is how this is
gonna go i need you to go do this again
i need you to go do this again
and sometimes not yell not always not
yelling not spanking for putting socks
on the floor right but we're gonna be
late to this thing this morning my son
has is pathological about being on time
mainly because his dad's always late
and we were nine minutes late getting to
where he needed to be because we kept
going back and going back
that in and of itself i didn't need to
hit him i didn't need to scream at him
he got to learn the natural consequences
of that and i guarantee you tomorrow
will be different does that make sense
makes total sense
so um tell me something that gets you
fired up about your son what does he do
one of your two sons what do they do
wrong that you feel like i have to hit
him or i've got to yell at him or it
puts you in a rage give me an example of
a thing
well so number one let me just say
they're very very good kids and i i i
don't have to do it very often okay
something i tried to leave as a last
resort you know
my my style is
number one try to talk to a model to
them like you mentioned
uh two i try to go to do time out as a
second resort and then last resort i try
to go for spanking but this i'll be
honest the thing that i guess gets me
boiling i guess what your question was
is whenever i ask them to do something
um and they just and i have to ask three
four five times and they just refuse to
do it that's i think that's what gets
under my skin the most and give me an
example of a thing
um let's just
brushed it's time to brush your teeth
let's go go brush your teeth or
hey we need to clean up your room you
know your room is a mess you gotta clamp
your room before it's time to go to bed
something like that
and then they just
refuse to do it um
i'm not really having a whole bunch of
struggle with with the little one
um
it's more it's more of my older son the
five-year-old and
it really hasn't been a a real big
struggle
but lately it's gotten a lot worse and
the thing that has changed with him is
he's just started school so i'm thinking
maybe that has something to do with it
too i'm thinking your kid's probably
exhausted
i've got a five-year-old too and for the
last week and a half two weeks since
school started she's been exhausted
right and when i've got a five-year-old
who's exhausted she's running on pure
fight-or-flight
pure exhaustion
and i've got to be way more patient
walking her through step by step with
stuff
and so for a five-year-old instead of
saying get in there and clean your room
i'll go in there and say i need all the
clothes in this basket and i'm gonna go
get mine out of my room and make sure my
house looks my my stuff looks good too
hey i'm making lunches for tomorrow i
need you to join me in this because we
all agreed this is who we're going to be
if you do timeouts for the sake of time
out what you're doing is using your
relationship as a weapon
if
you say hey we all agreed that if we're
going to be in here together we're all
going to treat each other with
disrespect i mean with respect and then
your kid is disrespectful as loud as
yelling et cetera then you let your
child know i'm heartbroken that you
opted out
for three minutes or for five minutes
one minute
for a year in age but they learn that
they're choosing to step away or i might
say to my kid i don't understand why
you're choosing to yell right now
because that's not helping solve this
problem now there are five so what i'm
doing is i'm teaching them over a series
of 1 2 5 10 15 years
you can control
how you respond to situations
but also they're going to watch how dad
responds to situations and brother you
can't let a five-year-old get your blood
boiling because they're five
right
you can't let a three-year-old get your
blood boiling dude because they're three
right
so for you man i want to back all the
way up when you're a kid
think about what you told me
and what i would do is challenge you on
this
your dad's your best friend you're so
grateful that he was a disciplinarian
that he was strong and i love that mine
too so grateful but there's always going
to be a gap
until you lean into it
between
you know what ultimately my dad didn't
choose to walk alongside me didn't
choose to lean into
our disconnection he didn't choose to um
teach me he got angry and ultimately
he had to hit a six-year-old
does that make sense
yes and there's going to be a gap there
in your heart between i needed that and
did i really what did i do that was so
bad when i was five
that was that required physical violence
and again
very very rarely i've spanked my son too
okay
um for
for danger type things not for you're
not doing what i say and i've got bigger
muscles than you
because we lead so far upriver when
we're parenting our kids it hardly ever
gets there almost never
okay
and
you're gonna have to deal with the
bullying that you experience as a kid
you're gonna have to deal with your
anger you're gonna have to do that and i
tell you you're not gonna have to fight
it all your life if you choose i don't
want this in my life anymore
and so your wife says i've got to step
out of counseling right now because i
feel like y'all are all ganging up on me
she's allowed to do that you can keep
going right
right okay absolutely and what i want
you and your wife to do is to get away
man you all get out of this y'all got a
three and a five year old you have
someone that could come keep your kids
yes you do i would love for you all to
get away and say we need to hit
ctrl alt delete on this
we've got a five-year-old we got a
three-year-old everything in our
marriage is different
um how's your intimacy life are y'all
still together
oh yeah absolutely okay i mean that's
something we struggle with you know
early on when the boys were babies but
yeah because you had a three and a
five-year-old yeah i mean you had a one
and a two-year-old or i mean i can't
imagine a three and a one year old yeah
everything's chaos
so you're slowly getting your marriage
back what i want you guys to do is focus
on building something totally new now
and
she's got to understand
that
um
you can't reckon with a three-year-old
they're not going to understand
explanations well when you do this it
makes mom they don't understand that
they understand modeling they understand
connection and they understand
um
uh
participation right
and
for you you've got to understand man
that every time you bow up on a
five-year-old he is in fight or flight
he can't think he can only respond
he can only be reactive
and so
being very patient have you brushed your
teeth no
we're not moving forward we all agreed
in our family that um we don't go
forward until we brush our teeth so i
need you to get up
a couple of nights ago i don't talk
about my family too
i i i've gotten my kid out of bed
several times hey we all agreed about
the bathroom we all agreed about the
kitchen table so let's get back up we
all you got to go take care of the
chickens outside whatever the thing is
right
and it's annoying and it's frustrating
cause i just want to sit down i just
want to go
but i'm a parent and that's my job
and for god's sake dude don't let a
three or five year old get under your
skin because they're three and five
but three and five and i struggle with
this man i'm not perfect at this
my promise here is we'll do a whole show
on spanking i've got some pretty strong
feelings about it um it's not really why
you called but it's hard to wrap your
head around this
um there is some really clear research
about spanking and anger in adults that
the lineage that that connects that too
there is some really clear um
research about
um
bowing up on a child and making them
just
shut down and then expecting them to
think clearly
is really hard
but we can have a whole other
conversation about that dude i'm i'm
grateful for the call out thank you so
so much for calling um you all can do
this but i want your wife to get away
reset your marriage say what what do we
want to do here
and ask her do i scare you when i'm when
i'm trying to teach the boys and let her
know man i'm really frustrated when
you're trying to explain something to
three-year-olds need to step up and do
it it's a complex complex thing i think
y'all can do this brother thanks so much
for the call hey we'll be right back on
the dr john delonay show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with betterhelp because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john dolone show listeners get 10 off
their first month at
betterhelp.com please reach out if you
need help that's betterhelp.com
deloney
oh
everything works better when i actually
answer the phone what's up lynn in
saginaw michigan how are you i'm great
how are you i'm a [ __ ] i can't work the
phones i'm good how are you
good good it happens it happens hey so
what's up how can i help
yeah so
my husband and i coach
cross country for a local high school
good for you i used to be a
cross-country coach
yeah we love it we really love it we've
been doing it for a while now do you all
run with them or do you ride your bikes
with them or do you all sit there and
eat donuts and yell at them and say go
faster
none of the above okay um we run on our
own
um on our own time but not with the kids
um
so we've dealt with a lot of parents
over the years as you can imagine but
we're dealing with
a specifically difficult parent at this
time and have been for the last few
years i'm just looking for advice on
how to work better together with this
parent for the kid's sake because the
kid is being put in the middle of
everything that's right
ugh so tell me about what's happening
um
the
parent wants to be the coach
basically
um and not be the parent um
and i did my heart breaks for the kid
and my husband is
digging his feet in
on how to deal with it and i'm a
peacemaker like i want everybody to get
along and be happy um
i think it's best if we all just don't
talk to the parent and
kind of just deal with the kid but i
don't know if that's reasonable
so um so i was a high school coach for a
few years and i had an opportunity to
learn from a couple of masters um that
were really really talented and they
taught me about coaching and about
boundaries and about working with young
people and it's one of the great
blessings of my life mike gibson and
troy
perkins coach perkins and um
troy kai some of these guys were great
what i'll tell you that i learned from
them both of them all three of them um
were so great was this
number one at the beginning of the year
they had a parent meeting do you all
have a parent meeting
oh yeah okay
i watch them and again i'm 21 years old
i'm a kid i'm a baby and i watch them
get up in front and say here's our goals
it's academics right um it is to instill
discipline and hard work and
accomplishment all those things that
every coach says to every parent group
but then they would also add
we are the coach
you are not
right we will not engage with you what
you think that what plays we should be
running what workouts we should be doing
we are the coach here and if you don't
like the way we're doing it you are
welcome to pull your child out
there's too many other options these
days
and it was a very clear we will not
engage with you
um
with
workout type plans with recovery type
like we're we know what we're doing and
we are the coaches
yeah otherwise the kid becomes the proxy
there and so anytime you get a
um
head coach let me put it this way you
can't solve this parent for that child
and that's heartbreaking isn't it
yes
it's hard when you're a teacher or
you're a coach and you run into that
parent who's just awful
and you know what they're doing to their
kid
and you feel like you're going to be the
buffer that you're going to save that
kid and
often you're not
what you can do is love the heck out of
that kid
yeah and every time you see him or her
you make sure you're looking them in the
eye and tell them that they're special
and that they're unique and they are
strong and all those all those things
that coaches do
coaches change more lives than
people would ever realize i'm sitting
here because of some coaches that
invested in me
but also you can't go to war with the
parent because the kid is the casualty
right right yeah and so somebody whether
it's you or your husband has to reach
out to the parent and say i'm not gonna
engage with you on this
yeah and they're welcome to go to your
principal i wouldn't even put that out
there um i have had people call and say
i'm gonna call the president and i'll
say here's their number feel free right
i'm not going to get into that yeah
they've
there's been several
very stressful meetings with the parent
and the athletic director yeah
so is the athletic director in your
corner
absolutely yeah so engagement time's
over
right we're done with that that's how i
feel just like what is also there to
talk about yeah we're done talking and
um it's with with the athletic
director's blessing i would send them a
note the next time they yell and if
they're parents that yell at you during
events you can tell them you're not
welcome at the event
period yeah and um it might be that they
throw a grown-up temper tantrum and take
their kid out of the event
unfortunately that's their that's their
right they're allowed to do that sure
and it stinks for that kid
and they will probably um probably
they'll just shut up because that's what
parents do they run their mouths and run
their mouths and then they just shut up
i got a talking to this year from a
little league coach not for not because
i was a mean yeller because i was a fun
i'm loud and i'm always making jokes and
cheering everybody on trying to have fun
and i would go to the dugout um and try
to pump up my son
and the coach said don't go the dog got
any more parents and i wasn't the only
one but they said don't do that let
these kids have fun yeah don't coach
them on the way home let them have fun
they're they're they're ten right and so
i gotta talk into all so you know what i
did i just shut up and i started having
fun out in the crowd with the other
parents and we had a blast so that's
most of your parents
if you draw a line and they want to
throw a temper tantrum and pull their
kid out then they're going to pull their
kid out they're going to find some other
school where they can parent coach right
yeah and every every season it just
comes to a
it comes to a head and it comes to a
meeting and i sit back and i just think
this is not what high school sports is
about it's not
just about winning and everybody
you know it's it it part of it is a part
of it's teaching competition and
you know being competitive but
we're we're teaching things that are
going to carry on later in life like
discipline commitment
you know and i just
struggle every year with this
looming
meeting that i know this is going to
happen but so i want i want to affirm
you to reposition the meeting
and i would love for you do you and your
and your husband co-coach
yes oh that's a wild setup have you ever
just like uh
rolled over in bed and been like hey i'm
not going in today you got it have you
just completely put him on blast before
that wouldn't go over well
uh that may have happened to me when me
and my wife were teachers but whatever
okay so
um
i want you and your husband to
sit down and get your principles of
coaching y'all may have already done
this
why are we doing what we're doing how
are we doing this what are your values
as coaches and then when you have these
kind of meetings go in with your health
held high
your head held high
y'all are running the show you're good
coaches your kids love you y'all do a
good job are all those things true
absolutely yeah and so when you're able
to untether because bullies can smell
that
yeah they don't want that
and they lean into that into your and so
flip it around i am completely
disconnected from a parent acting like a
four-year-old could care less
what an idiot a child what yeah exactly
what a child right the same as you would
do with a five-year-old
you look them in the eye and say this is
what we're going to do today you can
choose to opt in or you can choose to
separate yourself and this is how it's
going to go you'll have a great week
and
they usually will complain about there's
no communication
or i've been reading this stuff and or i
ran and call it great that's so good
here's how we're going to do this and
here's our workout am i on am i am i on
the right track
yes you are
ugh i'm starting to get like the the my
shoulders are clenching from when i used
to coach yeah um and
i have to remember that most the parents
most the time are incredible and they
love you and they're so grateful for the
role you play in your kid's life and i'm
not going to let one [ __ ] you know
blow it all up right now at all yeah so
if you and your husband can back out and
get on the same page principally and
values wise
then you can enter those things with a
totally flipped i look forward to those
meetings
because i get to say here's who we are
is what we're about and we produce
winners on and off the track and that's
what we're going for right yep and i
know it's so easy to say because that
one parent can just ruin everything
right
yeah and it always happens during the
season when it's the worst time it's
distracting it's championship season
you know it's it's just not worth our
it's not worth our time yeah there it is
there it is so really don't give it to
him
yeah there's nothing to meet about we
will not meet about our workouts we
won't meet about recovery
um if your child is hurt then you can go
see our training staff
absolutely yes right and so i'm going to
take the parent out of that conversation
and i know that's going to be
frustrating for them especially if
they've been pushing people around since
middle school since elementary school
um y'all are the coaches
and all of that will will change next
year because next year when you have
your parent meeting you can say clearly
we will not engage with parents on
workouts we will not engage with parents
on
um why and how we do recovery this is
how we run things
if you have some input you're welcome to
go get certified and become a coach too
and parents if you want to let your kid
participate
go for it i think i've talked about this
on our podcast but here's something we
did my kid had um one of my children had
some
educational meetings that me and my wife
were a part of my wife is a nationally
renowned scholar
in this particular thing she has a phd
in it she's brilliant she is in another
state right now as a college professor
she they fly her in to teach this stuff
i also have a phd in education and i've
been working with people in the same
area too
and when we met with our school my my
child's school
with the counselor with two teachers
with one of the assistant principals is
all great stuff just coming up with a
learning plan
you know what we asked hey what are some
books y'all are reading so we can help
be on your same page
we didn't pull any do you know who we
are do you know our expertise ah we
wouldn't be doing it like this because i
wasn't going to serve our son what we
want to do is support the teacher we
want to support the school and if it's
mayhem and it's chaos and they're
abusing my kid of course we're gonna get
involved
but when it comes to i think you should
run another speed workout instead of
just be quiet
just be quiet let your kids enjoy life
let them enjoy life
let them enjoy competition let them
enjoy competing let them enjoy have fun
and
while we're here i'll just tell you my
kids running cross-country
and sometimes i think man i think they
could do some more you know what i
challenged i challenged my son to a race
the other day we raced
and it was almost embarrassing for me
because he's 11. and i consider myself
to be in good shape it was real rough
so if you want to have more fun with
your kid go run run with them ride your
bike with them do some workouts with
them
leave these coaches alone they're
working their butts off
they're working their butts off we'll be
right back on the dr john dolone show
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that everyone has anxiety i've
been there and so have you
it's why i wrote this small direct and
personal book called redefining anxiety
in this book i discuss what anxiety is
what it's not and how you can get back
on the road of being whole and well
listen
you are not broken and i'm living proof
that you can get your life back i wrote
this book so everyone could read it not
just science nerds like me and my
friends and i priced it at 10 bucks so
that everyone can afford it this little
book landed on the best seller list and
is now being purchased by the case and
given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country i don't care if you're a
teenager or an executive or a 75 year
old grandmother this book is for
everyone so go to johndaloni.com and get
your copy of redefining anxiety today
all right we are back let's take one
more call let's go to
kyle in manchester new hampshire what's
up kyle
hey john thanks for taking my call
brother
you're amazing and i'm can't believe i'm
talking to you hey
i think you're correct
i'm just kidding i
i'll make it very amazing but hey i am
happy to be talking with you brother hey
what's up man how can i help dude
so i
my question is i don't know if i'm an
alcoholic or if i have boundary issues
and i think it's that i have boundary
issues and the alcohol is more of a
habit but
you're the person that can probably help
me figure it out cool man so thanks for
the trust here what what's bringing you
uh
what's making you ask this question
i mean
i i drink
quite a bit and how much you drink
uh
daily or five times a week um
you know quite a bit
how much when you when you drink
it's
i'd say i never have way too much to
drink but i'm also not the person that
has one to two drinks like i never black
out or anything but i
drink almost to get dr if i'm gonna
drink i drink to get drunk so you get
buzzed or drunk
four to five times a week six to seven
times a week
yes yep yeah you got a problem
okay absolutely 100
okay okay yeah um
why do you drink so much man why do you
think you why you have boundary
challenges
and and i guess that's you know the old
saying you know you're the average of
the five people you hang out with most
and that's why i'm thinking of the
boundary side of it is because everyone
that i'm around all the time
is drinking everything involves drinking
whether it's fam and it's family members
family gatherings
friends whatever like that so
um so tell me about these boundaries
though is it boundaries
meaning you can't say no or you don't
want to say no
or are you saying and doing things
that you wouldn't you wish you weren't
saying and doing
and you the common denominator there is
alcohol
yeah it's it's kind of both like i'll
say i'm gonna stop drinking
after the family barbecue but then the
family barbecue comes and i don't drink
for a week or two and then
before i know it the people that i
typically hang out with are calling me
and
one of the biggest people is
my brother-in-law and uh i've been with
my wife for
10 years now but when
she was 21 and i was 22 and
my brother-in-law was 19
their mother
passed away from suicide
and
so
since then my wife wants to be close
with her brother and
she's worked on all her feelings and
things like that but he hasn't and him
and i have become
extremely good friends
so it's kind of like am i doing it out
of the guilt that i feel for
i know that he's going to be at home
drinking alone if i don't hang out with
him
so i ha i say yes to hanging out with
him even though i've committed committed
to myself that i'm not gonna be drinking
as frequently okay and so like that's
why i that's the boundary side of it
okay
well
man the fact that you've thought through
it this this this deeply is really
really
incredible good for you man okay thank
you so backing out a little bit alcohol
use disorder i'm using the
uh i gotta
mostly hate hate hate love hate
relationship with the dsm but um
hey james put a thing down we need to do
the whole thing on the dsm one day
um the
it's the psychiatric manual that helps
diagnose people alcohol use disorder um
out of the dsm-5 it's a problematic
pattern of drinking and it can be a
number of different things usually they
want you to have two or three of these
things but if you've tried to quit over
a period of time and you keep falling
back into it
um
drinking for longer than you want to
right having a strong desire or urge you
like man it's about three o'clock you're
like dude i just need to get down to
work so i can grab a beer
or two or three right
if you find yourself have you just
started skipping stuff
hey we need to get to work i'm good or
i'm pretty hungover or sounds like
you're a social drinker that drinks too
much but that you can
you can
scratch and claw your way through the
next morning is that about right
yeah and yeah and i would say i don't
skip things but like the family
barbecues for example everything's
everyone there or a lot of the people
there are going to be drinking so i go
and drink there and i don't skip it but
and i don't lay in bed all day or
anything like that i get stuff done that
i need to but
i find myself drinking when i do it okay
and what benefit do you get from it
honestly that's
i think that's my biggest
thing is like i was listening to the
call from uh august 30th with the woman
that was talking about how she how to
have fun without drinking but
i don't even do it for
the fun of drinking it's kind of like
and that's why i'm like it's
i'm doing work around the house so i'm
going to have a few drinks you know
is there stuff that this
helps you numb from
uh i would
say yes i took that aces
test that you talk about yep um and i
took it three times because some of the
questions were like i don't know if that
is exactly what had happened but um my
score was three to five on that i got
three four and a five depending on which
one i took like okay which time and you
hopefully you read enough around there
that once you get into four and five
you're talking about a physiology that's
different your body works differently
because of some of the challenges you've
experienced right
yup
and when your body's running hot here's
the thing about alcohol dude it works
right it works
it does slow some of that stuff down or
it makes some of those those mundane
behaviors the ones that don't feel
reactive it makes you can get through
them makes them a little lighter for a
while all right
so here's
you probably know this
but i don't
but i'm gonna say it anyway
i wonder if you know how good your life
would be
with
a full night of sleep without alcohol
involved
waking up
opening your eyes and smiling when you
wake up feeling light when you wake up
no headaches no backaches no knee
hurting nothing like that just waking up
and popping up
or
what it's like to
sleep with your wife of 10 years with no
alcohol
just y'all are
madly giggly in love with each other and
you're out somewhere and one thing leads
to another at least another that's
probably been a long time am i right
you're right right
so here's the thing
quitting drinking will cost you almost
everything
and i don't want to sugarcoat it for you
it'll cost you some family barbecues
people will say oh look at look at kyle
fancy pants cut right that will happen
right um it will cost you relationships
kyle sold out dude kyle sucks he won't
even drink he's so oh he's so goody too
all that
right that will happen yeah and it will
be hard
um your brother-in-law who you love if
you really love him it'd be awesome
conversation to say hey we drink too
much
and i'm gonna stop and i want you to
come with me on this
and you can tell him how if he's your
great friend like you said he is you can
talk about your past and say i gotta
heal from some of this stuff you can
look him in the eye and say we gotta you
gotta deal with your mom
and we'll walk alongside you but we
gotta deal with this
all right
i love your sister uh love your family
but we can't go down this road and
here's the thing he's got to make his
hard decision on his own and he may not
choose sobriety he may not choose peace
he may not choose healing he may choose
a further trip down down the rabbit hole
right right right
what are you in for man
i mean you know like
i've i have
my wife and i have talked before and
you know we've stopped drinking for one
two months even over covet through the
holidays and everything and i felt great
and it's almost
i was thinking about right before
i got on with you and it's almost like
my identity is tied into drinking water
that's right so the two things you gotta
change is your identity and your
environment
okay and and with the environment that's
i think that's where it's boundaries is
so hard because
growing up growing up i never had real
friends or anything it was always people
that would steal from each other and you
know things like that but
now my
group is family so
those boundaries i feel like you know i
distance i don't talk to anyone that i
grew up with but
now the boundaries that i have to make
are with the family you know yeah and
dude as i say it's gonna cost you a lot
yeah and i is that like something i just
need to accept and
you know i know it's for the best but
yeah it's it's so here's a couple things
you can do number one know that you
can't do this by yourself
you can't just white-knuckle your way
through this because it's going to cost
you so much it's going to cost you
relationships your brain is going to
scream for you to reconnect with people
who are in your gang
and so you're going to be fighting
alcohol on one side of the of the
equation right the actual
chemical dependency part
you're also going to be fighting the
dopamine pain balance dopamine is about
anticipation and the moment think of it
like i heard it the other day which i
just love from andrew huberman
it's uh he's a stanford professor he's
brilliant wonderful but it's a
teeter-totter and the moment that that
dopamine it's about anticipation it
feels good the moment you
have that first drink it over corrects
with the pain part
think of it as a teeter-totter and you
literally get a pain
your body feels pain and that's what
makes alcohol so awesome as you cover it
up
and then the moment it's over that thing
starts to re-regulate itself so
it takes 30 days of
nothing
to get the chemical part through right
and at the same time you have to i
create a new identity and uh the way
i've done this in my life is backing way
the heck out getting one two three
people around me and to say
i'm a guy who takes care of their body
not a guy who snap into a slim jim i do
this workout i'm a guy who takes care of
his body
and that has things that that informs
sleep that influence informs alcohol
intake that informs how i deal with
anger that informs how i exercise right
that means some days i take days off
because i'm exhausted because i'm a guy
who takes care of my body not a guy who
can do 500 does that make sense
yeah yeah and some guys which i love
their identity is i'm the fun guy at the
party
i'm the guy who
always shows up no matter what
and that's gonna be a hard identity
shift for you and so whether it's your
wife i i would challenge you to get
somebody else whether that's a friend
whether that's an aaa meeting whether
that's a counselor those aren't for
everybody because of your aces stuff i
think seeing a counselor would be
awesome if you can afford it i think
they'll be great
but walking through i need to deal with
some of this childhood stuff at the same
time
i'm gonna abstain
and me and my wife if we've done it for
one month we've done it for two months
i'm gonna do it again
and i'm gonna have some hard
conversations with my current gang
my hope here's my dream and i'm dude
this is a fantasy this is like unicorns
and rainbows and ponies right
um
is that you would be able to sit down
with your brother-in-law and say hey
dude we gotta stop
we gotta find different things let's
let's become runners let's be i don't
know you know what the thing is yeah um
let's become guys who smoke cigars
together and go for walks whatever the
thing is right but we gotta stop
drinking and that means i gotta go see
somebody you gotta go see somebody my
dream is
my mythology for you is and your family
is that you could call the folks to get
together for the barbecue
and say hey everybody we drink too much
like i love you guys and i've got to
start taking care of my body you got
little ones
uh no no okay not yet are they in the
cards or or no
uh yeah they are um just
haven't had hasn't happened yet okay
awesome
so think about this as a
you're a guy
who thinks generationally not you're not
you're not a guy who thinks hourly
right right and so you can start
changing your heart and mind and
behavior now
because you are going to be responsible
for hearts and minds tomorrow
it's wisdom right right yeah and i i
completely agree because i grew up with
my dad being an alcoholic
but but he's
been going strong sober for i think
seven years now so
i saw the change he made so i know
that's what i want you know have you
thought about calling him and saying dad
i drink too much and it's time for me to
stop can you um
can we talk yeah yeah yeah i've i've
talked to him about it before and i have
gone to a couple of aaa meetings with
him
um
as support and just to check it out uh
but i've
because of those times i've been able to
stop for a month or two you know i'm
like well i know i can do it on my own i
just i all i can hear is dave ramsey in
my head saying just decide yeah just
decide here's you know there is just a
side
and part of deciding is knowing what you
can and can't do by yourself
mm-hmm right that's true so i'm just
gonna decide to start training for a
marathon tomorrow awesome
that means i gotta get a coach because i
know what i'm doing
or that means i gotta get two guys to
run with me because i'm just gonna i
know that i'm going to need some people
in my life right
so just decide doesn't mean you're all
on your own and it's all you just aside
means i'm gonna do some major things i'm
gonna decide today i'm gonna be a better
dad and a better husband that means i
gotta deal with my trauma that means i
gotta go talk to a counselor or a pastor
that i trust or a close buddy that's
been through this before that can walk
through this with me i'm gonna have to
get on the internet resources and
surround myself with fill in the blank
right so just decide isn't a flex it's a
submission
that makes sense
yeah definitely definitely so let me
tell you this
my greatest dream for you brother
is
that you can sleep
you can just go to bed
and the greatest dream is that you look
at the work your dad has done
that leaned into the work you're gonna
do
so that your kids will never know
they'll never know
you got both right right you grew up in
the home of an alcoholic which is his
own mess and your dad's done some hard
work
your kids won't even know what that was
that's a legacy right
and i don't want to sugarcoat this this
is going to change everything for you
everything
and yeah
and
it'll be worth it
i yeah i know it won't be worth it yeah
yep
tell me out loud
i'm kyle
and i'm worth it
i'm kyle and i'm worth it and my wife is
too
and my wife is too and my grandkids that
aren't even born yet they are too
my grandkids aren't even born yet are
they are too
that's hero brother
that's hero
yeah got it do you believe that
yeah i i do and um
i i
one of
if you have time for one more thing or a
couple more things um
or up against the clock so one more real
quick one
okay um so i try to stay off by like
retreat to
take care of myself and stuff but it
seems like something always comes up
like a family birthday or something do i
just stay home and let my wife go or
you know that's that's where having a
once you make this decision
and once you set up the parameters of
what that's going to look like aa is not
for everybody it may not be for you
maybe counseling is maybe a joining a
running group is right there's several
other options there what i want you to
do is i want you and your wife to back
out and create a world that you don't
have to hide from
i want you to create a world where you
can deal with the mundane and the
uncomfortable and the childhood trauma
and when your body sets off you can stop
and go what is that about that happened
to me this weekend
um i worked out way too hard i ate way
too less and uh way too little and i was
in the middle of a traffic jam and i
started thinking of stuff from years ago
and my heart took off on me and then i
started laughing
and said what are you doing
right it still happens but now i've got
some tools to deal with it and i didn't
have to pull over and go get gummy candy
let's go get gummy candy kids and ice
cream it or i didn't have to go stop
over and have a drink or what i was able
to just deal with it and then move on
okay
you can do that it's taking a lot of
work but you can do that i want you and
your wife to create a world that you
don't have to hide from
i want you to in your wife to create a
world together co-create this where
y'all laugh and have fun and it's an
adventure and it's exciting
and you can deal with the mundane
together and there's no alcohol in your
house period that's about the
environment
and
you got to get a gang you got to get a
couple of people whether it's somebody
from work whether it's somebody from
local church whether it's somebody in a
bowling well bowling
man there's nothing else to do when
you're bowling except drink but whatever
that is
yeah um
and then you gotta have a hard
conversation with your brother-in-law
then you gotta have a hard conversation
with
your family
but do it in that order because if you
just run out there and say i'm not going
anymore
that's rejection to them that's
rejection to you you don't have anything
to fall back on you'll be drinking by
the end of the afternoon alone right
okay right so do it the right way and
don't ghost people
it will be hard but part of who you are
and your new identity which is i'm a guy
who loves his family i'm a guy who tells
the truth i'm a guy who takes care of
his body part of that
i'm a guy who loves his wife i'm a guy
who loves kids that aren't even born yet
part of that will be truth-telling and
when you tell the truth and you have
hard conversations you will find
yourself get stronger and stronger and
you're going to need it because they're
going to reject you and they're going to
get pissed off at you
or maybe just maybe just just just maybe
they're gonna get a tear in their eye
and say
so grateful somebody finally said
something thank you so much maybe
probably not but maybe
and you're both cursed with a father
who's an alcoholic and blessed with
somebody with a father who's seven years
sober call him
and say i can't do this by myself
anymore
and i'm ready to make some changes
tell your wife that today too
tell your wife that today too if you're
struggling with alcohol
which a lot a lot a lot a lot of people
are
there's freedom on the other side of it
it's a lot of work it's going to cost
you almost everything
and it is worth it you
are worth it
all right as we wrap up today's show
james guess what i did this weekend
i went to a ucd store to mckay's the
greatest ucd store on the planet in
bookstore
oh my gosh that's amazing if i get hit
by a train and open my eyes and i'm in
mckay's and i'm holding a plate of
nachos i'll know i got in like i'll know
all know heaven is real and i made it
if i open my eyes and i'm in walmart i
did not i did not
i don't know walmart's not bad i don't
know why i'm back in walmart for no
reason but
listen i decided this happened a few
years ago i'm embarrassed to say what
i'm about to say is about 10 years ago
that i just went and got all the led
zeppelin cds and said i just need to
download them
i feel like i got a whole new band like
they're incredible and they were
different sloppy and messy and so good
all that
so this weekend i just went and got a
bunch of hendrix cds
dude
i feel like
everyone listening is like you're an
idiot
the guy's good man the whole thing
all of it it's a mess i like your method
of just kind of diving in deep because
there's so much music out there you just
gotta
just pick a catalog and just take a deep
dive and see if you like it well i feel
like you can listen to one hendrick's
song and it sounds like a jangly mess or
you can he's like all over the beat all
over the place or some songs he's like
playing his vocals backwards and
doubling the guitar and it just sounds
like a wreck but if you listen to it
sonically across oh my
like this was the first weekend actually
got it
whoa man so listen
start streaming everybody listening to
this start streaming just hendrix over
and over and over it'll it'll make
everything in your life a little bit
weirder but today's song dude this song
was smoking
jimi hendrix i don't know when this was
written let's just say a long time ago
it's it's um off the kiss the sky record
it's called stepping stone and it goes
like this
i sure got the blues this morning baby
yep i'm here to tell you all about it
it's kind of this whole show so you
might as well pick up on it i'm a man at
least i'm trying to be i've lived before
the other half of me i've lived before
that you don't want me but in this
search for nothing desperately oh i'm
trying trying not to be a fool i'm
trying trying lord to keep my cool baby
trying so hard to keep it together
and after i find baby that true love of
mine i'm just rolling screaming crying
flying can't be trusted but busted
rolling stone i don't have any idea what
any of that meant but that song is so
good stepping stone right here on the dr
john dolone show